let's go to the 503 area code caller
from 503 tell us who this is and and
what's your question today okay my name
is Trevor calling from Portland long
story short I was wondering what you
thought about the legalization of coca
leaf if you don't know what it is it's
the leaf that they made cocaine out of
coke oh I thought you said I'm sorry I
thought you said cocoa leaf like
chocolate yeah no the coca leaf okay
yeah no go ahead
oh yeah but the coca leaf is what they
make cocaine out of the forest mate and
who can't I'm sorry cocaine it's a
pretty mundane substance and I I saw
that the Prime Minister I think it was
Bolivia don't quote me on that yeah he
had a conference a speech where he
chewed it in the speech so it's not like
it's a destabilizing substance but right
I just wonder what your thoughts are on
it yeah here's the thing I actually have
studied this quite a bit it's pretty
interesting so in Colombia for example
there have been huge efforts to just
burn the coca leaf plantations of
farmers and the problem with this is
that you're not really if the if the
idea is to solve the problem of
addiction in the United States you're
not going to do it by burning the the
coca leaf plantations of farmers in
Colombia who make like a dollar or two
per kilo of coca leaf and the way that
it happens is you know you take all this
coca leaf huge huge quantities of it and
I think it's like a 30 to one ratio or
something like that you dry it out in
the Sun which reduces the weight
significantly gets rid of all the water
then you start mixing it with chemicals
and you make coca base which is already
a significantly more concentrated
substance then you take that and it's
further refined and condensed into
cocaine so I think it's something like
30 kilograms of coca leaf end up being
one kilogram of cocaine or something
like that the street value of cocaine I
don't know offhand this is not exactly
my area of expertise but I recommend the
book narco anomic SIF you're interested
in this I think the street value of
cocaine is like 80 to $100,000 per
kilogram in the United States or
something like that
if you burn half of all coca leaf in
Colombia you might think I'm really
gonna impact the price and the price is
gonna go completely bonkers in the
United States and people won't be able
to afford it anymore
no because they're only paying a couple
bucks a kilogram so once you actually
get through the full refinement of it it
has almost no impact whatsoever on the
street value in the United States and
it's one of the worst possible ways to
go about dealing with the issue of
cocaine addiction if you're trying to
deal with the health issue so you know
the coca leaf is legal in a lot of parts
of South America if you go to parts of
Ecuador very high elevation they make
coca leaf tea which supposedly helps
people acclimate to the high elevation
and it's not in and of itself in a legal
substance in those senses but you start
to criminalize it grown in large
quantities by these farmers it's just
part of the failed war on drugs in my
view so I don't know Trevor if you had
anything like more specific than that
but my view is that criminalizing it is
is about as useful as the entire war on
drugs has been I actually have a quick
question yeah does it have any use other
than making blow yeah yeah noble it's
used it's a tea and it's used to
acclimate to high elevation so like if
you go to the capital of Ecuador in most
of the hotels at least they used to you
you could get coca leaf tea and it would
help acclimate to the high elevation so
you avoid elevation sickness what is
that it I mean I had to get rest oh yeah
what the uses are and I noticed that
when I had like I had a really bad sore
throat one time I chewed some coca leaf
and my sore throat completely
disappeared I know it's an animal
analgesic analgesic it's a sort of a
numbing agent which I'm Cori you know so
yes it will it will help a sore throat
where do you live the world were you
when you were chewing coca leaf Trevor I
was actually here in Oregon all right
Erin Trevor sorry thank you very much
appreciate the call coca leaf lot to be
learned out there yeah